Deadly yogurt geyser set your phasers to
moist incarcerated toothbrushes smile
like a donut Microsoft fingernail
simulator I'm proud of my sand butter
flavored tree gas long B squeeze fight
molten dog hair we swam the way giraffe
see fall paper I wanted to sample some
spicy guitar but I couldn't fit the
napkin rounded tentacled popcorn there
are a lot of different ways to not make
any sense at all but of all of them the
fact that some people still don't have
access to simple healthcare despite the
fact that we live at the peak moment of
wealth in human history makes the least
sense of all partners at health is
dedicated to ending that weird lopsided
world they empower and equip local
health workers and have been working
with the people on the front lines of
the fight against Ebola before any of us
in the u.s. even knew that there was an
outbreak Ebola is a world health problem
antibiotic resistance is a world health
problem pneumonia is a world health
problem no community is exempt from
these challenges and Partners in Health
is doing genuinely heroic work around
the world to save lives not just now but
a hundred years from now Partners in
Health is a huge part of the ongoing
success story of increased access to
health care and decreased suffering
throughout the world and through our
support we will also be a part of that
success story for the first half the
project for awesome we'll be splitting
the money raised between partners and
health and an equally amazing
organization Save the Children will also
have matching funds for the first five
hundred thousand dollars donated meaning
that if we reach 500 thousand dollars by
noon on Saturday a total of a million
dollars will be given to partners in
health and save the children during the
second half the money raised will be
distributed to via your votes to watch
videos promoting charities and vote on
the ones that capture your interest and
attention head to projectforawesome.com
together through the project for awesome
we're gonna help the world make a little
bit more sense good morning John this
was my project for awesome video I'm
looking forward to seeing everybody
else's I would addition to making videos
watching videos voting on charities at
project for awesome calm we also have
the fundraising element that takes place
over an IndieGoGo and it's just a way to
donate to charity but in addition to
donating to charity and making the world
less nonsensical place you'll also get
stuff stuff that you can't get any other
way things like a reproduction of the
prop version of an imperial affliction
with Seth
pages repeated over and over again
written by John Green the author of The
Fault in Our Stars and also my brother
and the guy who also runs this video
blog would make an exact replica of the
one that shailene woodley reads in the
movie we also have a special edition of
The Fault in Our Stars only available
through the project for awesome it's
green everyone else we got a calendar
every year we got a calendar but this
year the calendar is big pictures of
youtubers including this guy so it's
cute we got a penny squashing machine
we're squashing pennies and stamping
project for awesome and nerdfighteria
logos on them that's the penny he's got
a couple hundred of these Hank ler fish
arts yeah
then doing that well watching Gilmore
Girls every one of these is beautiful
moment between a loving mother and her
wonderful daughter Catherine and I are
doing the full movie commentary of The
Princess Bride because we love that
movie you could compilations of dirt
fighting music an amazing nerdfighter
art that's just better than ever just
keeps getting more awesome every year
we'll be adding ton of frontier awesome
perks during the 48 hour livestream
can't spoil all the surprises now and
during that live stream of previous
years or in the indication we will get a
little bit silly and amazing things will
happen and we will be joined by lots of
your favorite youtubers or at least my
favorite youtubers and it's got to be
great the live stream will be running
from a Friday that's today at noon all
the way to Sunday at noon that's Eastern
Time noon not many other Noons now it's
time to take it back down again or the
outro thanks to everybody who helped out
here at the office and thanks to all of
you for participating in the project for
awesome whether you're giving or making
videos or hanging on the livestream or
all of those things our goal here this
weekend is just to help the world make a
little bit more sense John I'll see you
in the livestream